[Música]
hace 10 años casi 11 después de debatir
internamente con quien yo era empecé a
preguntarme si yo de verdad estaba
haciendo quien yo quería hacer si yo de
verdad me estaba vistiendo como me
quería vestir si de verdad estaba amando
a la persona que yo quería amar
y la respuesta a esto fue no
o simplemente porque me había dejado
llevar por algo que la sociedad me decía
y era ser heterosexual
y esto es algo bastante común en una
sociedad que nos permite reconocernos
si somos blanco o negro pero no si somos
gris según la onu entre el 10 y 15 por
ciento de la población del mundo
pertenece a los sectores el eje vete y
entendamos hoy acá el eje como lesbianas
gays bisexuales y trans
es decir que si traemos esta cifra hoy a
este auditorio encontraríamos entre 20 y
30 personas
lgd
y según estadísticas de esas 30 personas
al menos 23 han sufrido discriminación
por ser quienes son
pero todo esto cambia cuando las
personas hemos sobrevivido y hemos
sobrepasado este tipo de discriminación
y agresión
o cuando nos hemos convertido en ese
apoyo para personas que están en un
proceso de reconocimiento sin saberlo
nos convertimos en esperanza para esas
personas y como pasa esto a través de
las historias los seres humanos día a
día recibimos cientos y cientos de
información a través de las redes
sociales a través de los medios de
comunicación a través de la radio pero a
los cinco minutos no nos acordamos de lo
que vivimos pero cuando alguien nos dice
te quiero contar algo o quiero contarte
algo que me cambió la vida nuestro
cerebro inmediatamente empieza a
conectarse con emociones y esas
emociones se conectan con eventos y esos
eventos crean memorias en nuestros
cerebros y es a partir de ahí donde
nosotros empezamos a construir nuestra
realidad y nuestros actos
en colombia el 61% de niños niñas y
jóvenes usa internet como una fuente
principal de información para encontrar
soluciones a un problema de la vida
cotidiana y aquí es donde las personas
que hoy tenemos el privilegio de poder
ser quiénes somos tenemos un rol muy
importante a partir de transformar con
historias cómo estás
he trabajado muchos años en el vaticano
en la congregación para la vida del
ambiente soy gay
antes de aceptarme tal cual como soy
pasé por un proceso bastante difícil
lleno de matoneo desigualdad
discriminación les cuento que yo nací
también con discapacidad visual entonces
tuve que pasar dos procesos
respecto a mí y que si lo contaba hacer
algo positivo
como tal aunque nunca me gusta jugar con
muñecas de media feliz cuento con
carritos y estas cosas siempre sentí que
quería ser niña o que me sentía mujeres
en tiempos diferentes y me di cuenta que
existía otra manera de poder amar que
uno también podía amar a una mujer
y ahí empecé a darme la oportunidad de
conocer y de vivirlo
era el tesoro que tenía para una persona
porque así como yo tengo ojos cafè esto
nos tienes azules así como yo tengo el
pelo crespo que no tienen liso así como
yo soy lesbiana que puede ser gay
transexual travesti bisexual es otra
diferencia más estudiantil para
compartirles un mensaje en el cual le
digo a todas las personas sexualmente
diversas y con géneros diversos que no
están solos y solas esté todo ese tiempo
pero que no se pierdan sus momentos tan
hermosos de la vida sus zonas por las
perdices
a todos les digo la vida activa de
mejorar realmente no puede encontrarse
hay más gente como yo descubrí lo bello
de la diversidad con esfuerzo con
dedicación con autoconocimiento una
autoterapia que yo creo que todo es una
sensación tan liberador es tan hermosa
cuando tú puedes decirle al mundo
[Música]
como ven hoy en día el internet nos da
la posibilidad de llegarle a todas las
personas que nos necesitan y que
nosotros también llegamos a las personas
que queremos llegar pero nuestro rol no
es solamente a partir del internet
también es a partir de nuestras acciones
cotidianas las personas lgtb tenemos
miedo de ir a una entrevista de trabajo
y que nos pregunten con quién vivimos
porque no sabemos qué van a pensar si
decimos que vivimos con una pareja de
nuestro mismo sexo tenemos miedo de ir
cogidos de la mano en la calle con una
pareja de nuestro mismo sexo porque no
sabemos cómo nos van a mirar no sabemos
si nos van a decir algo tenemos miedo
que gracias a nuestra expresión o
identidad de género seamos agredidos
verbalmente o físicamente en un baño por
no pertenecer a lo que dicta un dibujo
como éste
hay una frase del poeta británico samuel
taylor a la cual encuentro muchísimo
sentido pues ésta nos dice que el
lenguaje es nuestra herramienta para
tomar acción y hacer con él que todas
las personas tengan un lugar en este
mundo
qué pasaría si hoy salimos de acá y
ustedes le cuentan a alguien que no sabe
qué es el eje que hoy vieron en este
escenario a una mujer lesbiana que puede
ser y vivir en un país como colombia qué
pasaría
si hacemos una entrevista de trabajo o
si conocemos a un hombre en una fiesta o
en una comida y no asumimos que tienen
novia o esposa sino que le preguntamos
si tiene una pareja para poder
permitirle a esa persona ser quien
realmente es
hace unos meses una niña de 14 años me
busco para decirme que gracias al
haberse encontrado representada en
historias como éstas ella pudo aceptarse
como mujer bisexual y asimismo lo hizo
su familia en un entorno completamente
religioso y esto es lo que nos dice es
que los seres humanos cuando no
conocemos algo nos alejamos cuando no
sabemos de algo lo dejamos atrás pero
cuando eso que conocemos lo empezamos a
vivir y lo empezamos a sentir más de
cerca empezamos a dejar el rechazo atrás
por eso hoy quiero decirles que cojan
estas historias que los mueven esas
historias que los tocan y usen las no
las dejen morir usen las dándole un
lugar a todas las personas lgtb de que
lo necesitan
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah